our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us we're
introducing you this morning to two
strangers who come together to help the
homeless it began with a teenager's
passion to put a new spin on clothes
from thrift stores Jamie yuccas met the
team distributing special clothing
that's more than it seems these are all
applications I think normally put these
on jeans while most teenagers are
piecing together their weekend plans
Dylan Iceman's life has one common
thread his sewing machine you like being
creative yeah what you wear like really
makes a difference in how you feel
inside I think that's kind of what
sparked my interest in designing but the
17-year old doesn't design for himself
or his friends Iseman takes used
clothing from thrift stores like
goodwill and transforms them into trendy
pieces for people who are homeless or
just scraping by the malibu california
teen says his inspiration for the
project came three years ago after
visiting a homeless shelter at the Los
Angeles LGBT youth center with his
parents when you actually get to meet
people who are on the streets it really
changes inside of you and you feel like
you have to have like a mission to help
out but first he had to learn how to sew
Iseman turned to the Internet and soon
enough adopted his motto upcycle uplift
I thought to myself I could do this for
a lot of people and make them feel good
I put this velvet ribbon on top it was
the teens eye for up cycled fashion that
caught Caitlin Adler's attention Caitlin
Bern do you have the socks Adler's
nonprofit project Narnia redistributes
donated items at weekly pop-up events in
Los Angeles I do get a lot of kind of
damaged or stained or just super
outdated stuff so then I reached out to
him when I saw what he was doing and I
was like this is great and a partnership
was here every couple of weeks Adler
looks to iseman to take someone's trash
I've never seen shirts with padding in
the shoulders
and turn it into something special this
is the blue shirt that gave me that's
totally different
yeah on the day we visited the pair at a
homeless encampment in Venice Iceman's
designs didn't sit on the rack for long
thank you Thanks what do you think of
these two the clothes and trying to have
a really righteous it's that sort of
response that drives Iseman he started a
nonprofit called fittingly enough so
swag the teen hopes one day he can take
his mission worldwide ensuring no one
who receives second-hand clothes ever
feels second-rate I'm already interested
in fashion and if I can use that to help
others it's just a win-win so this is
just the start for you god this is just
the beginning that's cute for CBS this
morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles he is marrying
his passion with helping other people
there's nothing better than that
absolutely yeah this way maybe he can
make some CVS backpacks for good and do
yeah